This is about the time
when you might say,
what does this have to
do with computer vision?
>> What does this have
to do with vision?
>> I'm so glad you asked, all right?
Well, another way of phrasing what we've
been doing is, given some sequence of
observations, which model was most
likely to have generated those?
So using our previous clothing and
weather example.
So, suppose you're seeing some
sequence of clothing, right?
So you, you check the clothing that
people are wearing each day, and
you see this, coat, coat, whatever.
And then the question you want to
ask is, is this Philadelphia,
Boston, or Newark?
The idea is that presumably,
what you've been doing is,
you've been collecting sequences of
these observations from Philadelphia,
a bunch of them from Boston,
a bunch of them from Newark.
You have a trained a model, and
we'll talk about that later.
You've created a model that will tend
to generate sequences, like you see in
Philadelphia, or in Boston, or Newark,
with the same statistics that they have.
And then given some new observation
sequence, you'd like to say, you know,
which one is this?
Now, notice that if we were
checking Boston versus Arizona,
you basically wouldn't
need the sequence.
It doesn't rain in Arizona,
for the most part.
And you could say,
well do I see umbrellas, okay?
And since it's always lousy
weather in Boston, I live there,
if you see bathing suits,
you know it's actually Cape Cod.
So the idea is, you know, just from
the individual elements themselves,
you could determine whether
it was Boston or Arizona.
The whole idea of
representing the time series
is that there's something about
the sequentiality that matters.
It's the statistics of one
thing following another,
that is indicative of the actual class.
And what you're doing is,
you're building some models of those
time series, so you can then given
some observation sequence,
you can say which one's most likely.
And what we're going to to do is, we're
going to apply that to computer vision.